still a lot of mysteries surrounding the
two bodies found at lake mead recently
yeah one of them has been ruled a
homicide but investigators say
identifying those people is not going to
be easy victoria saha in studio here
after talking to the county coroner
about what the process
entails the coroner's office certainly
has their hands full on a regular basis
but now with two skeletal remains
they're continuing to pour in all their
resources to help identify them but it's
going to be a lengthy process until we
know who they are and there's a good
chance we may never know
it's a case that has gained
international attention a body found in
a barrel which was under lake mead for
decades though discovered in the spring
of 2022 officials believe this person
could have been there for at least 40
years we did determine that it was an
adult male
we did determine based on clothing that
the time frame was consistent with the
70s and 80s and the cause of death is
gunshot wound and just six days later
skeletal remains were found under the
sand both remains now in the custody of
the clark county coroner we are
optimistic that we will be able to
to get dna
but however that will be actually
submitted to another agency clark county
coroner melanie rouse says in both cases
they were able to find a good amount of
dna from the teeth and bones now it's
just a matter of finding a match you
look for consistencies or points of
concordance that can be matched up to
determine if the individual's records
that you're reviewing from when they are
live match what you're seeing at the
time of their death and if there aren't
any matches the coroner's office will
rely on tips coming in
what's challenging in this case because
it does have such a prolonged interval
is that we may not have those
comparatives available
so we're really relying on somebody at
some point reporting a missing person
rouse does emphasize it is too early to
tell how the second person died although
they are not ruling out drowning
so as you both heard there's still a lot
of work that needs to be done here yeah
clearly i mean and one of the key
questions about this that a lot of
people are asking when it comes to
dental records how do they find that
dentist i mean is there like a national
database for this kind of thing yeah it
was quite the talker right here ralph
says that that's not the case but if
they narrow down who it is then they can
actually subpoena that dental office to
get those records but obviously they
said the biggest thing right now is
trying to find dna from blood relatives
the coroner's office says after they
have exhausted all their options the
remains will then have to go to a
funeral home this could be a long drawn
out story and we'll be following it all
right victoria thank you